stop you're messing around
[Music]
Terry Hall lead singer of the English
Ska band the specials has died he was 63
years old
[Music]
[Applause]
boom time
[Music]
the specials released a statement on
Twitter that Terry died Sunday December
18th after a brief illness the band
wrote a statement on Twitter praising
Terry as a wonderful husband and father
and added quote his music and his
performances encapsulated the very
essence of life the joy the pain the
humor the fight for justice but mostly
the love
[Applause]
[Music]
says you make tomorrow
the statement continued he will be
deeply missed by all who knew and loved
him and leaves behind the gift of his
remarkable music and profound Humanity
Terry often left the stage at the end of
the special's life-affirming shows with
three words love love love when I woke
on stage my initial reaction is oh my
God where am I and then I realized where
I am and um I just sort of get lost in
it all I just want to try and
communicate and um this is the only way
I know how really Terry was one of the
founding members of the specials which
came to prominence in the late 1970s
with their debut single gangsters off of
their self-titled debut album
[Music]
like helping
[Music]
me
[Applause]
this album also included a few of the
band's biggest hits including too much
too young and a message to you Rudy
[Music]
in the early 80s Terry left the specials
along with a couple bandmates and they
formed the band Fun boy three
people play
[Music]
Terry also fronted the bands the color
field and Vegas before reforming with
the specials in 2008. how has getting
the band back together been for you
mentally really fantastic because it's
it's
um
just a sense of belonging really